[Musique]
les prochaines nuits risquent d'être
ferrique le ciel nous offrir à l'un de
ses plus beaux spectacles les perséides
une pluie d'étoilés filantes ce sont des
petits grains de sable qui se frotte à
l'atmosphère terrestre des vitesses
colossal qui frise les 60 kilomètres par
seconde ce qui est énorme
une poussière ni du sillage de la comète
swift auto qui rend visite au soleil
tous les cent trente trois ans ces
petites particules en fait vont se
frotter à l'atmosphère terrestre et
devenir des étoiles filantes des petits
bolides en fait aidé venir s'éclairer
tout simplement dans le ciel que soir
elle défile au dessus de nos têtes à des
vitesses vertigineuses entre 50000 et
cent mille kilomètres à l'heure
mais cette année on prédit un très beau
spectacle
parce que la lune qui parfois peut être
un petit peu dérangeante quand elle est
pleine ou très lumineuse se rapproche de
la phase de la nouvelle lune cependant
il faudra composer avec une météo
capricieuse et des risques d'orages mais
dès demain il sera possible de les
observer cette année le maximum et dans
la journée du 12 août et on peut
observer la nuit qui va précéder la nuit
du 11 au 12 août et la nuit suivante du
12 au 13 août pour bien les voir il faut
s'éloigner des lumières des villes
choisir un endroit dégagé et lever la
tête vers le ciel ici à semi trail et
radio canada montréal